demand applause wherever he goes
every time hey guys all right ted's here
the first day of fall is just around the
corner and our good friend michael mack
from max pond is here with a look at
what's trending when it comes to fashion
for men
well we got some beautiful stuff here as
you can see you know max pond we sell
not only ladies uh luxury but men's a
lot of guys get left out right yes but
we got a few samples of some guy stuff
some great keep all bags limited edition
this happens to be a virgo ablo uh who
just recently passed his influence um
he's the uh the author of off-white and
we brought some other great things a
little camera bag here's a nba co-lab
with louis vuitton
so it's all nba on one side of course it
has the monogram on the other
so we got some cool stuff fun stuff and
very affordable well yeah that's just it
when we're talking about this bag or
anything up here normally if you were to
buy this at retail price what would this
run well this is a six thousand dollar
bag
um
but here's the good news you buy it for
six thousand you put you put in your
closet for a week it's worth ten today
and so it's kind of a crazy thing over
the the pandemic if you would have
invested in louis vuitton stocks gold or
diamonds what would your best best be
i'm guessing it's going to be that
they've had four price increases in the
last year that's incredible
so you know invest and shop at max pond
i would say right so obviously you are
or not charging ten thousand dollars no
no no this bag's on sale for 4 900. so
it's a great deal wow and a lot of our
buyers go and post things themselves and
make make money on top of it so that's
fantastic and is this becoming more of a
thing among men because i do have uh
what my kids call a man purse and they
make fun of me all the time but now i
can tell them i'm in fashion
you're a fashionable guy i mean you know
the the bum bags or the belt bags are
super popular this is kind of a cross
body bag yeah you know we have keys we
have phones
we go to football games we like it all
compact right right and make sure your
stadium size because if it's bigger they
might let you in that's right yeah i've
heard of people getting too allegiant
and all of a sudden it's not a great
thing finding out they can't go in where
at least they have to ditch the purse
somehow not good when you walked over a
mile to get there exactly all right you
have sunglasses too right so we have
designer sunglasses from uh these are uh
tom fords try them on kendall i'm sure
you'll look good
i'm going to be a guy fieri all right
all right so we can do this together
and i like i like the price tag hanging
from it i think that's a nice effect if
you're gonna be my friend you guys
always have to have some i'll give it to
you to wear but you just got to be my
salesman exactly and see when anybody
wants this again these are highly
discounted compared to what you would
find them for online or at retail stores
exactly so we have handbags belts
wallets sunglasses
luggage
of course we sell fine watches and
jewelry it's really a high-end luxury
store and we're opening two stores uh in
the in the spring of fantastic 23.
meantime where can people find you now
you can find us on the northeast corner
of saharan jones and you can find us
online shopmaxbond.com all right it's
always good to see you thank you thank
you appreciate you being here uh well
mercedes any of this interesting you uh
all of it